everybody has called Steven Crowder an
abuser for months now last night I went
over a lot of the evidence with you guys
proving that Crowder is not an abuser so
about six seven months ago the daily
wire and Stephen Crowder got into a
disagreement so essentially the daily
wire offered Stephen Crowder a 50
million dollar contract you know I guess
Steven came out came forward and talked
about details of this contract he didn't
use the daily wire's name but I mean in
the conservative media space it can be
very much inferred about who it was and
he accused them of a couple things I
didn't read the t's and C's and I I
don't uh you know we don't actually see
the contract so we don't know but he
accused them of somehow stifling the ad
rates of all the creators which if they
do that I'm upset increase my address
um and then the second part was he
accused them of punishing creators if
they get demonetized on YouTube and he
fell felt like that was being in bed
with big Tech he felt like if you punish
creators for getting demonetized on
YouTube therefore you're cooperating
with big Tech and you're not really
freedom of speech you can say your
freedom of speech but if we don't push
freedom of speech to the limits then you
can't really say you are now I'm kind of
in the middle here I'm not really for
talking about personal business
contracts I understand where Crowder was
coming from but at the time it kind of
rubbed me the wrong way Crowder ended up
leaking like
um a phone call where the owner of the
daily wire
insinuated that you give them slave
contract I don't I don't know who cares
that's not even the point of this
um they get into a fight right and a
couple of months later Candace Owens
covers this story and
um so they get into a fight right
so they're in a fight right and honestly
I'm like he just kind of pissed off the
wrong people now Candace did have a
right to defend herself so she came
forward and said no I don't have a slave
contract don't know what he's talking
about she and on top of that she talks
about praying for Stephen that there's
more going on in his life but she's not
at Liberty to say okay
whatever so Steven takes this as a
threat now was it a threat wasn't it a
threat I don't know I have a hard time
believing she didn't know about his
divorce which she claimed to but yeah
who knows maybe it was a
miscommunication maybe she was I don't
know
um but essentially
this made Steven come out and announce
his divorce so he came out and he said
I'm getting divorced unfortunately
there's people threatening me behind the
scenes and Candace took this as an
insult so Stephen also announces his
divorce and he says he picked the wrong
woman now
I didn't really see a problem with this
I mean if you're getting divorced it
can't be the right woman you know what I
mean like are we gonna argue that's the
right woman she says he's playing the
victim I
I didn't really see it in this talk he
said he picked the wrong woman and on
top of that he also said not to go after
his wife so I I really did think it was
so bad my opinion right but Candace then
says to his wife that she can come on
the show and give her side of the story
I thought that was a bit messy you could
say Stephen struck first by getting
messy saying she had a slave contract
you know I whatever but what I want to
point out that like this is my point
is how women lie and destroy a man's
reputation without showing the contacts
so what a lot of women will do is
they'll play a clip to play the victim
online and then not show the context of
it so you know I'm asking the question
is Crowder really the monster the media
made him out to be now everyone said
he's this abusive gay man like this this
is the but when I ask like where is the
evidence of abuse and where is the
evidence of him being gay
it's crickets I there's no actual
evidence so you know and guys this is
this guy's business
um and so recently I someone reached out
to me and offered me the full context of
the clip that Candace Owens plays on her
podcast so I'm going to show it to you
um so this is what Candace Owens
reported now guys I'm not even trying to
go for Candace because I mean he said
she had a slave contract and on top of
that maybe she didn't know you know you
got to give people the benefit of the
doubt I don't know who knew what I just
think with this new information people
should see the full story so go ahead
cool to watch it's especially difficult
to watch because in this footage she is
eight months pregnant
um and the video essentially reveals
just how emotionally abusive he has been
and she is alleging that he has been
emotionally abusive to her and this
video all but confirms it so let's first
get to the footage I'm just going to
allow you to watch it in its entirety
gradual boundary
I do a boundary no no you just you just
did it I drew a boundary and abuses you
are not taking the car because if you
refuse to do right for things then I
will go pick up the groceries I've never
seen my groceries
stinks wood pellets my grill
I know it's not a reasonable effect
how about you first
how do you respect yes I don't know
I'm a man
would you let me dance oh yeah right
it's not expect Stephen give an Uber
okay Stephen I can't
feeling some constraints like I can't
see it like listen to me listen to me
you want to walk out right now listen to
me I can't go to the gym I can't go to
my parents I can't call my friends I
can't I can't be home you're gonna take
the car and leave me here Hillary just
think of how boxing is made me what do
you need me to pick up I'll get it I'll
be back on and back
[Music]
the only way out of it is
yeah there you go you throw your hand
you give up so easy
you give up so easily I just said the
only way out of this is discipline
respect assistant
right I love you but Stephen
your peace and sick
watch it sit watch it
watch it
well go okay
and I I need some space
and love you
I love you very much
I don't want that's the big problem I've
never received love from you and the
fact is when I don't look I need to do a
b c and d you just keep this one about
it you know no I love you more than life
itself okay
put on some gloves no but I love your
life itself that's not fair it's not
fair and it's disintended Hillary you're
right right now
someone
is humidity
worthy of a life worth no matter the
life
Hillary Hillary come on now I'm not
gonna engage I'm not going to engage
anymore I'm gonna go I'll get texting
what you need I'll get you to me
all right
I love you
I'm committed to you
guys I'm I'm not I'm not gonna do those
things you're not committed to anything
you're not committed to anything
together
okay so it says as Crowder heads inside
Steven gets angrier and angrier and by
his own admission screams I will F you
up at his pregnant wife Hilary who then
flees their home okay so this is a very
harsh accusation
and I wanna I wanna point out a couple
things that when I saw the clip he kept
saying
stop calling me abusive like this is
like I I just saw something completely
different than everyone else saw
I saw a guy in his own home
asking his wife to stop
asking his wife to stop calling him an
abuser
you know for all this feminist jargon
isn't that gaslighting isn't that
gaslighting to say your abuse is sick
guys I I thought we were conservatives
what happened to sticks and stones may
break my bones but words will never hurt
me that's not abuse it's not uh you
cannot like it you you can maybe think
he shouldn't talk to his wife that way
but really what I saw was if she just
listened to her husband
then it would have been a completely
different scenario if someone filmed
most people's worst moments where
they're in their homes it's not a it
might look bad so now you have a guy
that whose wife and this happens all the
time the feminists will get in these
chicks ears and just tell them these
women that they do no wrong not ask them
any of the important questions and and
the thing is these chicks will go to
their friends tell them one side of the
story because women were very like um
self-centered so we only think about our
side of the story we never think about
the guy's side so now I was given the
full audio after he got in the house
let's pull it
that is the context of that saying if
you go to your friend and you know that
it was not meant that way I'd be married
Stephen threatened to hit me Dr Walker
you want to play those games you want
okay I'll play those games I will [__]
you up okay I'm sorry I didn't either
way too fast that's exactly what
happened I will actually say that what
Stephen is saying right now is exactly
what happened okay
that terrified me and that is way too
far
and it can't but it's way too far to
claim that I've ever been to violence
you and you know what I this is let me
tell you something I appreciate okay
I appreciate that the way that he just
communicated what happened to you
is exactly what happened okay I was
louder
now what you need to understand was
you are a
big man
you have never said anything like that
to me before
okay you've never said anything like
that to me before and
it truly scared me okay and I need you
to understand that it truly really
scared me
I understand that you think he was going
to hit you at that moment I I was
walking out the door and then I was
scared to go back into the house would
we admit this I was across the house
when I yelled at you I wasn't even
within a Striking Distance you were not
within Striking Distance correct it was
yell it was so I wasn't even up
physically in her face but here's my
point here's my point it was bad that he
said that yes okay
he shouldn't have said it was wrong I
think you said that he caught himself he
said I didn't mean it that way
he tried to roll it back or whatever you
pull it back
now you had a right to be upset with the
verbiage of what he said and now I said
it I'm just saying in hindsight would
you agree that three months of what he
has gone through
is a little bit of an overreaction so I
need to clarify something okay can I
share some information maybe a lot of
progress if you said maybe yes here oh
yes yes oh yes absolutely yes for that
incident yes okay I agree with you okay
this is Crowder getting red pilled in
real time guys he did and this is what I
say it's so funny because the simps will
come in and say that I lead these men to
destruction when this is what
this advice got Crowder
I mean imagine being in your own home
and being accused of abuse 24 7.
and that that's what they're arguing
about is he's tired of being accused of
abuse in his own home and he says was I
near you were you actually afraid I was
gonna hit you and what she does is she's
talking about the Duluth model and what
the Duluth model does is always put the
man as the aggressor
um it was switched in like the it was
switched in the 70s and so what happened
is is they always presume that in an
argument the man is in the position of
power and my question is
where where is this evidence of him
hitting her ever
and she just said there she knew he
wasn't gonna hit her she wasn't even by
her you know ladies I'm sorry a lot of
the the stories your friends are telling
you are full of [__] they're not true
because women process everything through
our emotions we see everything emotions
first so a lot of our stories we just
see them from our point of view this is
a woman who had a nanny working a
hundred hours a week watching her kids
The Nanny was the primary caretaker the
nanny said that they tried that she
trusted Crowder with the kids more than
the mother
now the his custody could be jeopardized
because of Clips like this and this
freaking simp Army
comes at me because they falsely accused
me of leaking the kids names which is
false on Twitter all of these simp dudes
and they got outraged over that but do
you know what they didn't get outraged
of a man potentially losing access to
his children I can understand maybe
jumping to a conclusion from the clip
and if you're not familiar with this
type of content okay but we need to
issue retractions like retractions need
to go out because you know this is this
is wrong